you laugh you drink let's go gamers no
alcoholic tan that's good we're drinking
Tucket suru if it really no it's yeah it
is it's good I'm so glad I'm not poor I
promise
oh by the way I'm not like five - he's
definitely five - oh my god it's so tiny
average stand up and prove it okay stand
up and prove it he says the pain F's in
the chat guys come on it's not our fault
it's not our fault for people that are
short not me of course did I laughs I
think a lot boy I'm happy to keep
laughing boy what do you say shut up
your dweeb so scared
that's basically summarize everything
that's the entire what is it like thirty
hundred million seasons
it's amazing them know it's kind of
funny I got I won't laugh at that see
this is why we need to eat baby Yoda
Oh
can we sample the pufferfish oh that was
amazing I didn't laugh though sad I know
that's not what I think it is oh wow
this is what I've been trying to tell
you guys five minutes craft makes you
don't watch that subscribe to PT ply IQ
points at least 20 and a half woke up
this morning and found my cat's guarding
my basement like this Jesus Christ that
Photoshop I don't think it is Photoshop
they also started meowing the halo theme
does it count if I make myself laugh I
think yes flag didn't pencil today is
the same man who has allegedly been
licking girl's feet at bookstores and
library is the same man who has
allegedly been licking girl feet at
bookstores and library we need to stop
Obama hashtag stop Obama the man lick
his feet at the library
listen I'm being set up he's banning
setup that has to be an edit right those
two stories do not correlate sir you
were caught licking feet it's setup
vitaminwater sponsor
hey grandma what's the new flavor of the
vitamin water
Oh awesome I'll drink to that thanks
grandma
you know something is never gonna be fun
if it starts with this caption but I'm
willing to give it a go and that and
therefore I have a poopy Jesus damn it
Alexa frickin died Alexa fricking had a
stroke and fell down the stairs
cheers four strokes this dude eating for
the forbidden burrito old my golden
voice is that nice nice nice burrito it
does not register finally someone that
cares about the environment someone that
recycles plastic there's a lot of
vitamins in plants again they're just
jealous you're not having forbidden
burrito snitch-ass dogs okay what is
that it hop that what is that a follicle
brah
[Laughter]
are you kidding me are you saying what
that's so mean
yeah why did the license I gotta hit him
like that
me and the boys riding me out from Obama
who set me up I knew it Doug like a good
glug
we gave our new teacher a fake
attendance sheet bend over haha settle
there dick Hurtz in here all right come
on he's clearly in on it still funny
though I can still appreciate I can
still appreciate even if I my big brain
is like fake Grinch Oh
Colossus is crazy ten minutes I've seen
they I don't know what to say come on
man let the men play GTA 5 in extreme
south what the Frick bro bathroom yeah
Tish my momma always used to do this to
me
really good memories this is like ninja
in 30 years when he's half hospitalized
no yeah I do that that happens to me all
the time can always appreciate a good
relatable meme
[Music]
[Applause]
that melon shakes all right cheers
gamers Cheers
top ten women I've slept thanks for
watching well done Oh slurps oh this is
up Marzia feeds me that seems like a
weird kinky I don't know all right I
ruined it moving on
oh my man clearly France has superhuman
strength
okay that's the only reason is happened
I think it's the trucker's call I don't
care what people say
damn see he could save a crowd like that
takes a lot of skill
uh watch Elin dine saying no cringe he
did not die inside okay I know this is
the kind of thing people like oh the
design is so weird but that's what
happens when it people who innovate all
right first day laughs and then they
copy just watch watch it there's reminds
me of I think I seen this clip this is
one of my favorite clips Elon Musk I
don't know why that's how this came to
be I guess cuz they're both rich and
they're both philanthropists I think
entrepreneurs at the very least this is
Jack Ma he's the richest person in China
he owns the website Alibaba which sells
it's like Amazon but for Chinese
products basically and he is the most
annoying person I have ever had to
listen to and eelain has the this is why
I called artificial intelligence I call
it Alibaba intelligence yeah yeah you
know as a joke is funny if you that's
your reaction
Alibaba yes it's your company we get it
might end up being true you never know
information now it's basically with
speech yeah I'm always amazed by what
your vision about the technology I'm not
a tech guy
I think I'm all about life I think AI
opened a new chapter of the society of
the world that people try to understand
ourselves better rather than the outside
world it's so difficult to predict the
future this is great 99.99% of the
predictions the human being had in
history about the future all wrong zero
point like Noah's laughing of the
prediction right there right because by
accident yeah but it's also true that
80% of statistics are false so good it's
also true that 80% of predictions are
wrong
yeah this contradicts everything you
just said all the dumb [ __ ] you said 99%
of all predictions are wrong including
that one yeah people worry a lot about
this today are those people
I called them called called college
smartness people like us street smart we
never scared of that we think it's a
great fun and we want to change our self
to embrace it I don't know man that's
like famous last words
yeah it reminds me of Matthew
McConaughey because he'd recent got an
Instagram and he's just saying a bunch
of gibberish he's like one of these
people that you're not very smart but
you want people to think you are or at
least interesting and you just say a
bunch of gibberish like to have the
monologue just as you have to have a
monologue do that the dialogue so I'm
wild profound I'm looking forward to
what I want to share translate if it was
your funny bone it doesn't you think a
second it did really doesn't
let's keep the heii not low i high-low I
did he just make the bad sign
did you guys see that did you guess you
catch that like shut up dude you're not
interesting alright
it's the same character as Jacquemont
just change a biology to get there good
yeah well let's talk about something fun
night what do you think about that I
actually I'm not interested in a Mars I
just came back from there so hahahaha oh
my god he did the same on the earth the
things happening here so what why yes I
think this is a reason why I'm someone
no Vijay Kumar because it's such a
boring ass statement to say oh why are
we looking outside in space with like
earth it's more important we have issues
now with the environment that is really
pressing like yes there are issues on
this planet there's always been that
doesn't mean we can't look beyond and do
other solve other problems as well we
are literally overdue meteor hitting our
planet with like 40,000 years
statistically so I would say to not look
at other planet is extremely
irresponsible and to have someone a
private company a private person being
the forefront of that it's like it's
commendable I don't want to hear it from
this guy Singh I'm not interested in
Mars I care more about here I get it
okay I really get it but at the same
time you can care about both it is
possible just a one step you go to Mars
but you would never be able to come back
I hate to go to the Himalayas - I mean
when you climb on the I think someday I
would go there when the elevator is
ready I would go to have a look that
seems like words from someone that
worked hard to get what they they burn
rank maybe if there's elevator I will go
I wish I was the kind of person like
Elin that can hold it together but this
stuff it did piss me out
alright this became a whole tangent
let's let's keep laughing right let's
see what you guys send me on Twitter I
love this cat meme it's so cute and I
don't even like cat means
you know what the reaction is gonna be
but it's okay all right you know what I
think I'm gonna end that there before
bad bad goes bad epic all right if you
guys enjoyed this video
smash like subscribe I upload every
single day gamers come on let's get it
you can't not miss the next upload
that's it for me for now bye bye Hayden
see you tomorrow we're all excited about
the new game that's coming out and I
can't wait to play it it starts with the
letter P can you guess what it is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was coke come on dumbass
you stinky brainer
you